I introduced this example function to
you in order to help you think through
the two big things that so far we've
been doing with stationary points the
two big things are number one where are
they you got to find them you got to
locate them okay and so you can see
that's what I'm doing up here what am I
done what's my first step I I
differentiate because to find stationary
points I'm looking for where that
derivative is zero which is why I've
written here the first derivative is
zero when and then I that's very easy to
solve so you can just state those values
okay but that's only the first thing we
don't just want to know where they are
we also want to know their nature is the
way that we say write determine the
nature of these stationary points I want
to know not just that they are there but
what kind of stationary points they are
and so that's why I produce this right
so what do we call this thing what is
this it's a table of values and
importantly it's a table of values for
the derivative there and I check what's
happening at each spot and what's
happening around each of those important
spots now this is probably important to
mention I don't think I said it last
time so maybe grab your pen out this is
not just called a table of values is
also colloquially called a neighborhood
tests and the reason why is because the
first part where you found the
derivative and you found what it was
equal to zero you know what's happening
at these interesting spots you know
that's where the stationary points are
but what you don't know is what's
happening around the stationary points
and I was just having this conversation
with Eric actually what kind of a
stationary point it is is it a Max is a
minimum is it what's that last
alternative a horizontal point of
inflection which of one of those it is
depends on what's happening in the
neighborhood what happened before the
stationary point what happened after
okay now there's something a little bit
dangerous about this table of values so
just put your pins there for me and look
up at it what's dangerous is that
neighborhood like when you say all my
neighbor right what you mean is the
house directly next to you yeah you
wouldn't say ah down the street is my
neighbor you'd say that's someone who
lives on my street right but they're not
so close to you
now well we had a look at these values
we conveniently found for this
particular function you have negative
one in one so if you went like one unit
away you got this nice series of values
it's like oh this is convenient I know
that the function is going to go up it's
going to go across it's going to go down
it's going to go across it's going to go
up so there's my shape I know which
one's my back so I know which ones my
minimum okay the issue here though is
that I can very easily craft a different
function for you where if all you did
was say Oh negative 1 is an important
point let's just go one unit to the
right because 0 is convenient I like 0 I
could go one unit to the right and I
could actually miss all of this
happening for instance this curve it
looks like this at the moment ok well
it's not that it doesn't take that much
imagination to create a function that
doesn't look like this but maybe looks
like this now if it's so narrow if all
the important stuff is happening very
close to each other you can see if I'm
like oh here's an important point if I
go one unit to the right I've missed
everything I've missed all of this
activity that's happening in here so in
fact the image that I get from this
table of values is not very realistic ok
so therefore what I want you to put next
to you've drawn a lot of tables with
values by now ok so you can go back to
where you wrote this original one in
your theory or you can just go to the
nearest one that the most recent one
that you've written ok what I would say
is just be careful you must choose
values carefully you must choose values
that are here's the technical phrase
close enough that's not the technical
phrase at all
you must choose values that are close it
off and what close enough means I'm
gonna put it in inverted commas what
close enough means kind of depends on
the function right in this case actually
that's totally fine that like going one
unit apart gives you the perfect picture
and that's why I chose such a simple
example but other times like I've I'm
looking at out anyone but you guys know
be real enough that you could work out
who I'm talking about I taught in
schools where if you said one was the
stationary point they won't accept
anything less than saying zero point 9
and 1 point 1 that's the name
do you see it's it's closer in it's like
oh they're right close to each other you
have to say close enough though because
as you can imagine like that's a narrow
function I could just make a narrow one
and even that would be still too far
away does that make sense so close
enough is a very subjective term and it
depends on the function does I don't
know make sense you know say okay now
here's what I want us to do I actually
want us to draw this function we didn't
do it in a nice like a proper way we
just sort of got a general idea I want
us to draw this we've got all the
features I haven't got y-values yet but
you can quickly work them out and we're
going to draw a nice big one because
we're going to use this to understand
the next idea which is what my empty
heading is about so join yourself up a
nice fresh set of axes I've told you
what X values the stationary points have
but I haven't told you the Y values I
want you to draw this thing as
accurately as you possibly can off you
go
I'll um I'll play catch up so that you
can do at the same time
now you've already done that just just
draw the function function
Oh
actually I think I did draw this but
whatever
okay now hmm we're signing out a bit
better at this but what I'm going to
show you a little walk you through the
construction of my graph because there
are actually some steps here that I
haven't mentioned before there might be
handy okay wing draw we call this curve
sketching with calculus because now that
you know calculus you know like hundreds
of times more information about the the
shape of your graph that you did without
calculus so what I've put onto here is
the important points that I know I've
got the maximum turning point there that
I found before you can in fact even
label it as such
max turning point I've got my minimum
down here and I determined all of their
natures earlier on now in order to make
sure that my graph shape looks
reasonably accurate the most dangerous
thing that people do is something like
this just watch me doing this just watch
it they say stationary point stationary
point they never got to go there they've
got to go there so they draw something
like that because they're like oh I've
got to get to that point it's hard to
get the shape right this is all to
straighten angular okay a cubic curve
like ours doesn't look like this okay so
therefore in order to avoid this I
construct my graph in a very particular
order here's how I do it
where I have stationary points I don't
just label it as a point I draw in a
little horizontal line like that that's
my cue to remember well if these really
are stationary points that if I draw a
tangent it ought to be horizontal right
so this avoids me sort of coming down
and being too angular as I get close
okay then secondly I do the parts that
are easiest okay so see this is a
minimum it's going to go up after this
isn't it okay so therefore I I start
here and I just go whee that's really
easy to do it doesn't have to be super
accurate I have the right shape I'm
happy with that
just like on the right hand side the
left-hand side is also easy cuz see
that's a maximum so before this it was
it was down here right so therefore just
like before I'm going to go like that
and I've got nice neat curves all that's
left is the pie in the middle which is
the trickiest part I've already worked
out by looking at my function what my
y-intercept will be can you see what the
y-intercept is it's seven so it's right
smack bang in the middle there
convenient so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to slowly
if I had a pencil I'd use a pencil here
draw a nice curve just so it fits there
okay it takes some practice to be able
to do that so go easy on yourself but
use a pencil these are pencil if it
turns out terrible just rub it out give
it another go
once you're done at the HSC level you
probably should go over the whole thing
in pen because it'll be easier to scan
but let's worry about that let's cross
that bridge when we get there